foreign
[Music]
how did we get this a map so detailed so
precise
that guys like this would have thought
it was magic an impossibility made
manifest by superhumans in the future
one of their fellow explorers Ernest
Shackleton Drew this place on the back
of a menu once dreaming of someday
Crossing this whole continent and paying
a huge price to try
this is a place that has lured explorers
from all over
killing many of them
that's because the bottom of the earth
is a place that humans really shouldn't
go
it's a place that in fact they couldn't
[Music]
hey I'm super excited for you to see the
rest of this video first I need to say
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring
today's video I actually use storyblocks
to make this video I didn't go to
Antarctica for this video I got a lot of
this footage from storyblocks which is a
giant repository of loads of tools that
you can use to make your own videos from
over a million 4K and HD footage Clips
animation templates music sound effects
images and more I mean it's a lot of
stuff it's all searchable it's all there
you can download as much as you want for
One monthly subscription I've been using
storyblocks for literally a decade
before they ever came to sponsor me for
a YouTube video and it's kind of a dream
to work with them recently storyblocks
changed the game by creating a plug-in
for After Effects and Premiere which are
the programs we use to edit and animate
our videos what this means is you can be
inside of your editor and have access to
all of this footage so you're not like
downloading it and moving it to a
different folder you're just grabbing it
from the storyblocks panel inside of
your software it's truly amazing and I
just found out out at all of this
footage that I shot from Switzerland and
Greenland is actually up on storyblocks
now like you can go and download as much
as you want of my beautiful images from
these places in addition to hundreds of
thousands of other amazing visuals this
is an incredible service that comes at a
very affordable price it's a set price
it's not like hidden fees you can
download as much stuff as you want for
this one set price I'm a huge fan so
thank you StoryBox for sponsoring
today's video there's a link in my
description it is storybox.com Johnny
Harris clicking that link helps support
this channel but it also lets you learn
more about how this service can help you
up your game as a visual Storyteller
whether you are an individual Creator or
a big production company storyblocks can
help you let's get back to this video
about Antarctica our species were able
to move and settle across the whole
globe from desolate ice deserts to
impossibly far away Islands somehow we
just showed up we settled
but even after we had reached every
corner of the globe thousands of years
ago there was still one landmass that no
human had ever laid their eyes on
but something had to exist down here
they thought something to balance out
all of the land in the north with land
in the South so explorers and map makers
continue to search and on these Maps
they drew their imaginary ideas a giant
continent somewhere down here or maybe
this island out in the East really
extended down like way down maybe there
was palm trees and abundance a new world
yet to be discovered
others mocked the idea of a southern
World they depicted it as a dystopian
land full of Kingdoms Rife with
immorality but these were all guesses
it all remained unknowable
too far away to find out
[Music]
by the end of the 1700s explorers had
turned most of the world's oceans from
Mysteries to fact and it is only then
that the vast ocean expanses of the
South turned from imaginary musings into
the next Frontier of Discovery the newly
enlightened map makers were now drawing
precise gridded lines to accurately
audit the planet they were done with
their pretend predictions their monsters
in place of knowledge
the map would remain empty until they
had evidence to fill in those great
blank spaces hopefully with Earth's lost
and last continent for thousands of
years conjectured by many but seen by
none
[Music]
so Expeditions were launched moving
south and they failed the southern Seas
were simply too vast the gaps in our
knowledge too big to take on this
Uncharted place but in 1772 one Captain
would begin to change everything
[Music]
sail with two ships and 192 men and with
him the latest technology a new clock
the most precise clock ever made at the
time and would for the first time allow
him to determine his longitude to map
his every move to give us the lines that
we can now show you on this map this
journey was funded by the all-consuming
greed of an expanding Empire looking for
new soil to exploit but him personally
he had big things going on in his mind
he was in it for the desire to go south
further south than any man had ever gone
and as far south as any man could
possibly go he wanted to be the one to
find the Lost Continent at the bottom of
our planet so for three years he scoured
the oceans yet searching in the
temperate latitudes all he found was
water so he decided to cross a line that
no one before him had crossed the
Antarctic Circle
[Music]
in case it's not clear we're now looking
at the bottom of the world and this map
is actually a story it's a story of a
doggedly determined Explorer spending
years of his life circling these oceans
dipping more south than any human had
ever traveled then coming up and then
dipping down again just in case this
time he might find something but all he
found was frozen water floating ice
sharp and perilous but he kept on
looking for ways in on a couple of
occasions he reached within breathing
distance of land but he never caught
sight of it after years of searching it
was finally time to head home he didn't
find the continent
but what he did do was prove that if
this fabled land existed it would not be
the Bountiful Paradise that people had
imagined and hoped for he had scoured
nearly every inch of those latitudes
instead he knew that any land down here
would be a desolate World quote forever
buried in snow and ice
so more explorers go and attempt to do
what Captain Cook couldn't and 45 years
later
they find something
it was the Lost Continent and humans
were laying eyes on it for the first
time no it was not temperate but Barren
and merciless but it was seen it existed
for human beings A Moment Like This
doesn't mean the end of a goal it
actually just means the very beginning
so they don't stop here soon more ships
are heading south explorers looking to
claim land for their country seal
hunters Whale hunters looking for new
untouched Waters scientists on boats
with measuring tools and open Minds
recording everything the unknown place a
little more known sketched on paper the
shape of a land mass but these records
only served as a new measurement of our
ignorance how much we didn't know our
discoveries were still scattered and
partial a crude shape a ghost of
something much bigger to truly unveil
Antarctica's Mysteries we needed to
venture inside it
a few years would need to pass before
the people with power would turn their
attention slightly away from mapping and
conquering the non-icy world to
supporting the full exploration of this
desolate place but eventually they got
on board they needed to know what
existed in the last blank land on the
map by then they had unleashed the magic
of mechanical power power that was fed
by carbon from ancient trees turned into
black gold locked deep in the Earth this
new power allowed them to navigate The
Once impossible ice unlocking the
perilous interior on board these boats
were scientists explorers ready to ask
and answer new questions armed with new
methods new tools progress Discovery
adventure and of course the French being
French soon it's 1911 and there's a race
to see who can get to the South Pole
first and it's the Norwegian group who
does the British team gets their second
and everyone dies on their way back and
the map is shaping up new goals come to
replace old ones we now need to cross
Antarctica through the pole going
through the ominous unexplored region on
the map a guy named Shackleton tried
this but didn't make it very far but his
journey became a tale of Courage and the
will to live when he and his crew
Against All Odds in some of the most
hostile circumstances managed to all
return home the Expeditions of that
period reset the standards of human
limits and bit by bit line by line the
void on the map was gradually getting
filled in by 1920 you're seeing Maps
like this a red shading on the parts
that we know and yet still so much left
unknown after Millennia of dreaming of
it we finally an indisputably conquered
the skies we were now able to lay our
eyes on Uncharted territories at an
unprecedented scale the first airplane
flew over the South Pole in 1928 and in
the next decade many more would follow
each flight providing more detail to add
to the compendium of hard-fought
observations
but as much as it is a part of our
nature to explore and learn it is also a
part of our nature to conquer and
dominate in the aftermath of the most
catastrophic War Humanity had ever known
humans once again revealed their little
Eternal Paradox that their love for
exploration was often as much about
conquest and control as it was about
learning and understanding Petty fights
about who owned this land came to the
surface and thus on the maps more and
more we see these shades of colors
unnaturally straight lines that indicate
who owns what
scientific research stations dot the icy
surface flying national flags
established as much for asserting
territorial control as for Science and
now it's a new world where the two
superpowers had turned the map into
their chessboard for influence both were
now looking for a share of what was
still Earth's largest unexplored
territory and soon the United States is
making Maps like this that has a whole
shade color dedicated to land that has
been seen exclusively by American eyes
it's a map that says we were here first
creating a paper trail that they could
point to just in case they needed to
stake a claim here at the bottom of the
planet
but then the countries get together and
they make an agreement that Antarctica
was not meant to be just a new field for
our conflicts but rather a place for
scientific inquiry so scientists keep
coming enabled by better technology
icebreakers and helicopters are unloaded
onto the continent but despite all the
progress this continent remains unknown
and potentially unknowable
that's until humans break a seemingly
impossible barrier by escaping the force
of gravity that kept us bound to our
home planet we're now throwing up
spherical machines with cameras on them
into space countries use these
satellites to Snap photos of their
enemies on giant rolls of film and gold
canisters that would fill up and then be
ejected back down into the sky
intercepted by an airplane and now yes
we have photos of what our enemy is up
to but look we also just have photos of
the earth seeing it like never before
[Music]
terrestrial outlines that old
cartographers would tediously
reconstruct with only the help of
scattered observations math and plenty
of imagination now readily available to
us with perfect accuracy our Maps were
no longer educated guesses they were
snapshots of reality thanks to our
satellites hurling around our planet
once every 100 or so minutes taking
photos and making measurements while
they fly humans have outdone themselves
now we have more data than our human
brains could possibly comprehend it's
too much it's basically worthless due to
its scale its detail its complexity
until New electronic brains appear
allowing us to collect and synthesize
hundreds of thousands of images from
space blending them into one map
a map that explores who broke into this
desolate place a hundred years earlier
could have never imagined every nook and
cranny of Antarctica is seen every Hill
every curve every Valley every Cliff
every ledge but we don't stop there now
let's measure the radiation emitted from
the icy surface we can measure the
chemistry of the atmosphere down here
the temperature of its oceans the
velocity of its ice sheets as they move
we can somehow even map what this place
would look like if you removed all the
ice ice that let me remind you is four
kilometers thick in some places
scientists soon declare that Antarctica
the place that was always inaccessible
to humans is now the best mapped
continent on Earth
oh
this generation's long quest to map
Antarctica is ultimately a story of
struggle and then Triumph a story of
exploration and Science and to me it's
rock solid proof of something that seems
to be deeply embedded into The Human
Experience the obsession to discover
regardless of the cost and despite the
lack of any rational reason to do so
always driven by these twin motives of
curiosity and Conquest always willing to
do whatever it takes to step foot in a
place no matter how impossible it seems
so yes we've basically entirely mapped
Antarctica and the entire planet at that
but you know we're not going to stop
here as New Frontiers reveal their
Mysteries to us the same story is bound
to unfold and I can say with certainty
that we will continue to do this not
because we need to for survival but
because we need to for some other reason
some deeply human impulse that pushes us
way past what's reasonable into the
impossible to expand the frontiers of
our knowledge to understand ourselves
and our surroundings a little better to
discover the truths of our world and our
universe
hey everyone thanks for watching
um this was a new format obviously one
I'm really excited about though because
we poured a lot into making this
beautiful and immersive
um Tom and I like developed this
soundtrack in a very very like bespoke
like tailor-made way and my hope is that
it really stuck
um I know for me this is like one of my
favorite videos we've ever made
um I want to tell you about something
because I'm very excited about this
I made a poster it is a poster called
all maps are wrong and it features
dozens of map projections we can't
accurately map the world on a 2d surface
because the world is a sphere right and
so we get all these weird map
projections and they're beautiful to
look at they're kind of weird to look at
we just launched this like right now
like it's literally this is the first
time I'm talking about it to you right
now and what that means is there is a
pre-sale discount 15 off for this week
only to support the channel
um we have Luts and presets that we use
to color our videos and our photos our
members of The Newsroom are also a major
pillar of our community that's our
patreon and they get access to an extra
video every month a behind the scenes
Vlog as well as a bunch of other perks
that you can check out over on
patreon.com Johnny Harris
um I started a company called bright
trip that is all about smart travel and
smart travel products video products you
might love that
um and just being here watching these
videos commenting showing your support
really actually helps in a big way so
thanks for being here
um I'll see you in the next one bye
everyone
[Music]
thank you